[Music]
developing this afternoon an east valley
business gutted by an early morning fire
las vegas fire says it was a warehouse
that burned near pecos and stewart and
right now investigators are trying to
search for the cause hector mejia
reports
electric liquidators an equipment shop
in the east valley left in ruins at
pecos and stuart it's a warehouse that
was previously subdivided into different
businesses sounds like the fire was
towards the front
of the building video shared by las
vegas fire and rescue shows intense
flames shooting from the top of the
building when the first cruise rolled up
it spreads real quick it doubles in size
every two minutes so especially like
this one here when we arrived on scene
fire through the roof
so that tells us that this fire was
burning for a little while the first
reports came from a passerby and a metro
police officer around 3 45 friday
morning usually people call those in
quickly we're able to get to it and put
it under control quickly many times our
calls come in from
police officers on patrol security bus
drivers
once in a while a passerby
and again that was hector mejia
reporting the incident brought out as
many as 40 firefighters from las vegas
north las vegas and clark county and as
we mentioned the cause is still under
investigation